the family of 13 year old Nathaniel
Kling is asking for your help to find
him they say Nathanael is a warden of
the state and ran away from childhaven
over a month ago no one has heard from
him since Victoria Saha spoke with his
stepmom who's doing everything she can
to find him
but my biggest fear is someone alert him
Krista Lee Harless speaking to us from
Tennessee worried sick about her stepson
Nathan Kling initially we really thought
maybe he'd try to come to Tennessee or
go to Oklahoma where his aunt is but
without him showing up either place it's
scary the center for missing an
exploited Children released this flyer
of the 13 year old he was last seen on
February 2nd his stepmom says he didn't
get on the school bus the next day to go
to Martin Middle School he would get on
a city bus
instead of the school bus so they
weren't super alarmed but Lee Harless
tells us since Nathaniel went missing
she learned there were numerous times
where he didn't return to childhaven and
they still trusted him to get on a
buffalo
I don't I can't even fathom that
Nathaniel has had a hard couple of years
his dad died in 2019. he continued to
live with his step-momently Harless in
Tennessee but she tells us his
biological mom wanted him back with her
in Las Vegas then he was taken away from
her and sent to childhaven it's been
more than a month
where do you think he could be
yes
I have no idea it scares me to death Lee
Harless believes Nathaniel is still
struggling to cope with the loss of his
dad which may have triggered him wanting
to run away because there was a possible
sighting of him at his dad's grave in
North Las Vegas on the same night
flowers were left at his dad's grave and
we confirmed with his uncle that we have
no idea who left them so we kind of
think it was Nathaniel Lee Harless has
made a Facebook group called five
Nathaniel Kling for anyone wanting to
help search for him Victoria Saha 8 News
Now
this is the most recent picture of
Nathaniel you can see he has much longer
hair here if you believe you've seen him
please call Metro Police